you have dochi on the album who's one of
my favorite new artists obviously she's
incredible she's from Canada yes she's a
I I I did radio in Tampa so it's dope to
see uh her doing her thing but she's a
person too and she's like very high
level creative like I saw her when she
first time with TD she did like this
like industry performance and it was so
crazy what was it like working with her
all of that like we have kindred spirits
and you know I just as soon as I heard
her music I loved her and I felt her
spirit and then when we met she just
told me how much of an inspiration I was
to her and and watching me gave her you
know a lot of um confidence to just do
her you know
um and you see that you see that she is
somebody who's tapped in you know to uh
her Innovation and what makes her unique
um and I love that about her and and it
was beautiful we were in the studio we
had so much fun making phenomenal like
that song
because when I heard persuasive I was
like oh I love this song I love it and
so when we got together when I was
working on my project I was like oh you
would be perfect for this sort of of of
song and I didn't even tell her I played
her like five songs I don't even tell
her this is a song I want you to be on
she heard phenomenal she's like she
jumped up said hey so she's she's just
humble creative a beautiful person she
came over last night to celebrate with
me oh nice yeah she I didn't even know
she was coming she surprised me so
that's dope
um for you did you have any idea that
you were gonna break Twitter when you uh
Flash the crowd when you were performing
because you you own Twitter for about a
week oh my God no I did not I literally
was at my friend's party living my life
as I always do and you know
I did not I I was having a good time I
felt like I was in a safe space right
and that's it I was honoring exactly how
I was feeling
so yeah because like did you I mean you
had to have some sort of idea this is
gonna be on the internet a little bit I
was very shocked that I mean when aft
after after
I realized that there were so many
cameras you know because I try not to
live my life like I'm Janelle Monae
there are cameras let me let me let me
not yeah and and these and the party
that I was at was uh the same party that
inspired my album so I know a lot of the
people who were there and you know
they've been to to my place and we've
created a safe space with everyday
people and with Wonderland and in our
parties and so
um it didn't really come out until like
that video was older it was old so
somebody was like well let me now
capitalize and that's the world we live
in yeah let me capitalize like it was
nobody posted anything safe space and
then when they sort of Saw
um
I think my visual that I put out they
were like oh well while we're here I saw
her laugh you know last week but it's
all love free the nipple free the nips
free the nipple I mean Rick Ross has
freed his nipple I support him you're
right about that D'Angelo when he did
Untitled he wasn't freed his nipple you
know got from behind that piano and
freed the nipple you know I could go on
and on DJ Khaled has freed his nipples
many times right DJ Khaled you know we
support free the nipple right for all
people I agree yeah and it's a double
standard that t-shirt wrong
yeah and so it helped with the promotion
because now everybody's like I mean you
were trending yeah you know listen I
live my life I think I never think like
oh this is going to get them talking I'm
having an earth experience and of
honoring all of me I love it that's it
that's all I can do